uma da minha palestra vai ser mulheres
computadores e criatividade
eu defendi meu doutorado em criatividade
computacional em 2003 e desde então após
ter trabalhado há algum tempo nesse
tempo eu diria que esse tema vem se
trabalhando em bonn primeira pessoa a
aventar a questão da criatividade de
máquinas foi a da loureira se eu não
poderia começar essa apresentação sem me
referir a ela nada logo eles é é um
limite é de 15 essa questão já foi
levantado em 1833 na época ela se
referia aqui máquina a máquina analítica
debate do qual ela foi colaboradora
porque o que a levou a essa questão
ela teve uma mulher na época vitoriana
ela era filha do lord byron que foi
talvez o mais famoso poeta romântico e
teve o mar vida amplamente extravagante
da época é logo após o nascimento dela
mas não ficou decepcionado por ela ser
uma uma menina e um mês após o
nascimento ele esposa se separaram
quatro meses depois ele assinou a
assinatura de separação e pouco depois
ele deixou a inglaterra e morreu quando
a data tinha oito anos de idade ela teve
pouquíssimo convivência com o pai lá de
baixo levou uma vida muito extravagante
da época ea esposa dele ana bela não
queria que a ada sobre essas influências
do papa nada foi educada principalmente
pela avó
judith que proveu prada uma educação
esmerada a águia desenvolveu um forte
habilidades matemáticas analíticas o que
deu errado na época uma mulher ter um
perfil matemático é um só a roda afirmou
que as máquinas elas não podem ter a
pretensão de originar qualquer coisa
elas podem simplesmente executar o que é
o ordenado a elas o que você saiba como
ordenar que max ela se referia então a
máquina analítica
o debate essa máquina era o um conceito
de um computador moderno
ra máquina de barba de se tivesse sido
com seguida teria sido algo assim ela
teria cerca de 25 mil peças
pesaria cerca de 15 toneladas e teria
cerca de três metros de altura em que
era uma máquina que só calculava a
adição e subtração
a preocupação de barba e era com relação
às tabelas matemáticos tabelas lugares
por exemplo era calculado por contadores
humanos e que frequentemente tinha
muitos erros tanto no cálculo quanto nas
transcrições
essa máquina a morte dela foi construída
e apresentado em 1943 se não estou
enganada mas depois ela foi construída
em 1989 na inglaterra para dizer que se
ela poderia ter se conseguido na época
com a tecnologia
em decorrência disso a água é
considerada a primeira programadora nova
de não tinha um grupo de pesquisa mas
nada ela se corresponder com ele
desenvolveu um algoritmo para cálculo da
seqüência de belo ir e até hoje ela é
vista como associada à questão dos
computadores e da criatividade máquina
mas radar afirmava que é reconheceu que
a máquina analítica debate poderia
compor peças de músicas elaborados
científica de qualquer grau de
complexidade extensão
mas a criatividade envolvida deveria ser
criada a onde de creditar ao engenheiro
não houve gente em 1950 e replicou
colocando que a argumentação é
equivalente a dizer que nenhuma máquina
é capaz de surpreender e frequentemente
as máquinas agem de maneira inesperada o
conjunto iniciais da máquina em geral
desconhecido mas o que é que a atividade
que estamos falando de criatividade de
máquinas aqui então nós vamos nos apoiar
uma outra autora margareth boury que ela
é uma psicóloga computacional a primeira
vez que eu vi esse tempo eo isso peso
ela faz terapia de roubo
mas não ela estuda modelos
computacionais visando é simular
processos cognitivos e dessa maneira
então entender melhor como os processos
cognitivos do homem funciona
bom agora em julho e apoiada em outros
autores
ela define a criatividade como uma
característica da inteligência humana
baseada em capacidade do dia a dia tais
como associação de idéias memória
excepção pensamento analógico e uma
idéia criativa é tal que é nova suíte
onde surpreendente e de alguma forma
valiosa e isso é muito importante não
basta que seja não tem intervalo tem a
gravar a agregar porque esse não é
apenas novidade vai definir três
principais identificou três principais
modos de criatividade criatividade
combinatória que envolve combinações de
então a reserva sem poesia analogia onde
as idéias são associadas de família ou a
a criatividade exploratório alguns
atores não consideram isso criatividade
é quando você descobre algo que já
existe mas em todo o processo criativo e
isso a faz de exploração e finalmente a
criatividade transformadora é a crise e
atividade associada aos grandes
cientistas ao grandes artistas essa sim
é considerada grande criatividade e na
mão e difícil do que ela envolve a
transformação do domínio em voga assim a
expansão de alguma dimensão bom
desde então na área de inteligência
artificial alguns autores eles têm
aplicado computação e relativa para a
simulação da criatividade
nesse livro ram do penta e colhe várias
aplicações são apresentadas e nós
inclusive já apresentamos um capítulo
nome àquele diagrama redor da nossa
contribuição nesse sentido
em um jogo dramático de um sistema
evolutivo você produz promoções por
exemplo nosso carro
aí são constantes é música são conjuntos
de quatro notas musicais a partir daí
então rastilho de promoção são
selecionadas aplicado um crossover em
cima do crosse uma mutação uma função de
fitness e seleciona um cluster para ser
tocado levando em consideração os
aspectos biológicos harmonix
esse curso é selecionado e vai para uma
produção sonora então que resulta disso
é entre aspas música tal mas é uma
composição sonora ea própria margareth
bolden é lá com ele escreveu uma
abertura para esse livro ela coloca eu
gosto ou permutação avaliação a seleção
é reprodução são aptos para simular a
criatividade como da core e exploratório
já a criatividade transformadora essa é
difícil até para seres o bom
a partir de então já aqui eu vou
apresentar então duas aplicações uma no
domínio visual outra no domingo xodó de
computação evolutiva é é a partir de um
barco de pesca disse que vai apresentar
a seguir foram criadas alguns objetos
foram programados por um aluno rafael
maior e foram geradas composições
visuais a partir desses objetos dessa
maneira então vocês é essa
esse foi o palco escolhido nós temos
vários objectos aí então nós aplicamos a
computação evolutiva no caso dele irá
mais generativo do que permitir para
algumas aplicações
a associada àquela composição dessas
existe aqui um cromossomo que tem um
fundo e tem uma um conjunto de objectos
e nós podemos por exemplo fazer
casamento de composições não poderemos
fazer uma composição como a primeira lá
que só tinha triângulos pegar uma outra
que só tensões ea partir daí gerar uma
composição com triângulos e sós por
exemplo
então uma vez apresentada uma composição
domínio visual
esse é o nosso trabalho é um trabalho
bastante complexo no domínio senom então
o workshop que foi apresentado aquele
diagrama que apresentei anteriormente de
repente ele foi aplicado no ambiente
rural
o lux foco ele tinha curvas que eram
desenhadas tem usuário e essas curvas
guiavam a produção sonora
nós fizemos um experimento envolvendo
cti e ônix e é um aluno aí no caso tem o
flávio eu desenhava curvas na tela do
computador que eram enviadas como
trajetórias para os robôs sistema de
divisão que aquele gol que foi
desenvolvido por nós no cti e observava
as trajetórias dos robôs no cão os
caminhos decorrentes da trecho das
trajetórias mhc dos caminhos percorridos
resultou uma com uma produção sonora da
produção foi capturada foi adaptada a
músicos humanos tocar e no último dia
nós fizemos uma apresentação aqui na
galeria da unicamp no dia houve uma
performance em que os robôs executável a
sua coreografia entre aspas produzindo
uma conseqüência da produção sonora
acompanhando dos músicos estavam
executando uma composição que o
princípio tinha sido resultado tinha
sido utilizado como estratégia
composicional o movimento dos robôs
o
é é o bumbum
i
o quanta criatividade e transformador eu
acho que sim oral de certa forma ele foi
transformado que não há humanos e
máquinas trabalham juntos produzir
resultados que não sejam obtidos
declaradamente foi assim um experimento
em que a bailarina e interferir na
composição sonora
os músicos tocaram uma música que foi
composta por comuns
se todos interagindo naquele ambiente
então não ao mesmo alguém a ser a grande
criatividade mas eu acho que se ele foi
um grande transformador
quanto à questão em seus computadores
podem ser criativos eu refleti bastante
tempo nesse tema eu cheguei à conclusão
que se com os computadores podem vidas e
criativas
obrigada